On est face à une pénurie.
Y a plus rien à manger.
En fait, ce qu'il se passe c'est que les villageois font grève.
Parce qu'ils ont appris que la reine du Sud là...
Celle qui a les dragons.
Et qui est très, très, très, très bonne.
En gros, elle aurait libéré des esclaves.
Et du coup, c'est la révolution.
Les villageois veulent plus nous fournir de récolte.
Plus rien à bouffer.
Heureusement...
J'ai ma petite cachette.
Belyr ?
Oui ?
C'est prêt.
Mangez, compagnons.
Je vous laisse ma part.
C'est mon deuxième.
Je vais même pas le finir.
Nous, nous, nous, c'est la grève nous !
Nous voilà ce qu'on voudrait, c'est...
On veut pas décider les uns et les uns...
Non, non, non, ça c'était...
Nous on veut décider de chacun, tout ce qu'il veut.
Dans le... dans le...
Merde, le...
Pour être ensemble ! Voilà !
C'est ça la nouvelle idée qu'on voudrait faire.
Les gars.
Aelys ?
Rien.
Ils parlent comme des gogoles.
Mais leur terrible secret...
C'est que c'est vraiment des gogoles.
On veut plus les rois, hein.
On veut plus les gens qui disent...
Alors oui, voilà... On est les gens qui disent... Tous les gens...
Ce qu'il faut faire par tous les autres gens...
Hein ?
Alors, ce qu'ils veulent c'est une démocratie participative.
La vie associative !
C'est vrai qu'on aime pas trop travailler dans les champs.
Nous ce qu'on préfère c'est boire du vin...
Devant des feux de cheminée...
On veut voter pour le gens, qui sera la personne qui est la décisionnaire au milieu, hein.
Et vous avez un candidat ?
Un cadi... ?
Ok, donc ils ont pas de candidat.
Très bien, noble peuple.
Nous acceptons votre demande d'élire un nouveau chef, en échange de vos récoltes.
Ouais !
Merci Messire, hein.
De rien.
Par où sortoyons-nous ?
Par-là.
Super.
Merci, hein.
Je suis hyper déçu.
J'ai toujours été hyper sympa avec les villageois, mais bon.
Apparement c'est pas comme ça qu'on gère une dictature, alors...
Bon c'est la merde.
Les villageois font grève.
Ils veulent...
Élire !
Élire, c'est ça !
Ils veulent élire un nouveau roi.
Bon, autant vous dire un truc les copains.
Si je suis pas élu, vous finissez tous à la rue à bouffer des pipasses.
Et pourquoi ?
Bah parce que c'est mon château, en fait.
Ok, bon argument.
Alors, pour que je sois élu, j'ai réfléchis.
Faut, soit, que les villageois m'adorent.
Oh, ça c'est mort ça.
Voilà.
Soit, que les autres candidats soient si nuls...
Que moi je paraisse génial à côté.
C'est là que vous intervenez.
Pour qu'on se présente en tant que mauvais candidat.
Exact !
Soyez vous-même !
Elles sont trop hautes ces fenêtres.
Villageoise, villageois !
Bonjour, déjà, hein.
Bienvenue à l'élection du seigneur de ces terres.
Mesdames et messieurs, veuillez accueillir les candidats !
Si vous votez pour moi...
J'augmente les impôts...
De 70% !
Ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire, les sous sous beaucoup pour nous.
- Bouh !
Si je suis élue...
Je ferais en sorte que les femmes aient exactement les mêmes droits que les hommes.
Hahahaha.
Si je suis élu...
J'interdirais les sandwichs !
- Bouh !
Je donnerais le droit de vote aux femmes.
Hahahaha.
J'interdirais les promenades...
La joie de vivre...
Et l'utilisation des routes.
J'ai rencontré ma femme sur une route !
Et si je suis élu...
Je ferais exactement tout pareil que maintenant !
Ouais !
- Ils sont cons, ils sont cons.
Et le changement c'est pas maintenant !
Ouais !
J'ai gagné, c'est mort, c'est mort.
Allez, bisous !
Ouais !
Bah voilà !
La politique c'est pas si compliqué.
Et je suis toujours en course pour le trône, hein.